torrential rain is expected to make the
already flood ravaged South even worse
this weekend flood alerts are in effect
across six states this morning one man
was killed by flash flooding in Baton
Rouge Louisiana
Mireya Villarreal is in Prairieville
that's about 20 miles from Baton Rouge
Maria it's a good morning for some of us
but there how bad is the damage the bat
the damage looks pretty bad right now as
you can see this is what was left behind
in the wake of these storms this tree
was actually behind the home it snapped
and ended up on the roof you can't even
see the door anymore guys a lot of
families tell me they got the tornado
warning just minutes before this thing
hit massive flooding now covers parts of
Louisiana after hours of torrential rain
the rubbish and everything go in the air
oh my god severe storm slammed Gulf
Coast parishes creating flash flooding
and kicking up high winds tornadoes
ripped through the Baton Rouge area with
winds powerful enough to rip trees out
of the ground so the suction just blew
the door up and I guess Cassy Harper
barely made it inside the roof was
actually somewhat intact but the water
was pouring through and we got her bed
out of here hood and as soon as
Jeffrey's brother walked out the entire
roof fell your daughter could have been
in here yeah Harper says she was lucky
she took her kids to daycare early has
it hit you that reality that they could
have been home it has and it just keeps
coming in waves I have a meltdown and
then I'm okay and then I come in here
and I just cry intense rainfall and
flooding ravage parts of the region
trapping people in their homes and cars
rescue crews in Baton Rouge rushed in to
flood waters to save a woman after the
rising waters swallowed her car there
has been major flooding on the
Mississippi River in Louisiana since
March it continues to swell as
floodwaters make their way downstream
straining levees and dams leaving
hundreds of homes damaged
homes like Harper's where years of hard
work were destroyed in just seconds this
is our first home together and we worked
really really hard to get this house and
make it our home and it was our own and
it's just devastating local officials
are calling this an emergency and they
are asking for help with recovery funds
the Harper family tells me it could take
between 6 and 12 months before they are
back in their homes gail picture tells
quite the story thank you very much
Maria